this is not your first bday this is your
second I believe yeah what keeps you
coming back why do you love this event
so much honestly I went to my first one
not even understanding what to expect
and I just I was bawling I was so moved
by the teachers by the kids by the
energy and it makes you want to go home
and do more and accomplish more and
those are the days that are most
important do you feel like it makes you
want to teach your kids about getting
back more I talked to my kids a lot
about giving back and it's something
that's I always joke that I have an
actor and support my charity habit but
today is really special because I have
my daughter here today and she gets to
see firsthand what these kids her age
are accomplishing you get the cool mom
card a little bit bringing her to
something like this you would think I
would get the cool mom card but she's
like so blase I was like who do you want
to like see Sophia Carson she's like mom
I know Sophia Carson I'm like okay no
I'm joking she's really excited I did
ask you about summer Blaire how is she
doing she's amazing she she's Selma her
sense of humor is intact and maybe her
body is not where she'd like it to be at
this very moment but it's not gonna stop
her from doing anything people really
love your guys's friendship
how does she inspire you you know I joke
like I have a cold and I don't want to
get out of bed for two weeks
and this girl just does the school run
every morning and is out there birthday
parties and it's not letting an illness
stop her from accomplishing everything
in anything
I also find Instagram this really cute
poster with like husband appreciation
day a new poster day cute is husband
appreciate what like I'm not exist right
isn't every day huh it should be like
wife appreciation day off yeah is he
gonna plan anything special for Mother's
Day coming up I should probably remind
him it's coming huh never gonna see you
guys share the screen again that is my
ultimate dream I doubt it because then
his home with children they can take a
joint into like the whole family thank
you so much good
[Music]